wim coumans donc au vert c'est une main
de quoi c'est parce que j'ai des copains
c'est mon bizutage sur la poésie mon ami
j'ai les clés dans la poche oui dans ma
poche
et c'est quoi ça c'est que des menottes
là dans ma poche là là là ici j'arrive
pas à attraper
donc on n'est pas pêché seigneur c'est
pour te rendre service à charles et léo
n'a dans la poche là
s'il te plaît ainsi il va pas m'arrêter
moi où je vais arrêter ah oui c'est quoi
oui non oui là enfin
service maintenant je suis plus le
loisir
d'y en touche comme ça tu es commence
déjà à en tourner un film porno pourquoi
emmerdes oh non non non non plus clair
j'ai pas mis cent la veille oignons
c'est pas sympa
sinon j'ai la clé dans la prochain
attendait parce que là ça va pas le
faire ou la whey
way
oh la la qu'est ce que c'est je suis
désolé je suis parti trop vite
j'en ai un propre dans l'autre poche non
métalliques ou encore il
fallait donc tu ton père qui mena et
cegedim ont visité m'ont mis pleins de
truc c est clown rire oh non pas mon
blouson bird alors vas-y
alors arrête
oloron prendre des points
mais ya que des six il ya les clés
potter
pourquoi
je suis fait avoir comme un bleu comme
un bleu non qu'il est attaché au
profit des enfants des tâches et en
rajoute les [ __ ] quelqu'un de
meilleur exemple est parti
et où là et vous ça vous fait rire les
enfants
selon m
[Musique]